[Music]
back to boris johnson uh
there are
more things that are obviously just
being brought to light in the uh the
scandal of the times but uh
this is much more funny to just kind of
get mad about from the people but they
are getting mad about it this is a list
uh that was leaked all items bought by
boris johnson during his flat
renovations
yeah they've just been leaked so
basically um he's got this downing
street flat that he's been renovating uh
the invoice has just been leaked news
first arose of johnson and his wife
carrie's expensive flat renovation when
the conservative party received a fine
over the refurbishments uh the items
johnson and his wife bought have since
been exposed and people are kind of like
what the [ __ ] so for example i'm gonna
save these uh notations in pounds
because we are sophisticated oh god is
it still 1.5 conversion because then i
could do mental math i'm gonna ask let's
see pounds i think it's less now might
be like one point one or one point two
yeah whoa
get your mental math ready all right
buddy here we go point two part
conversion dude
calculator i hate my reviews like for
example uh there's a 500 pound kitchen
tablecloth tablecloth what the [ __ ] bro
whoa what is that 600 doesn't he need
that on twitter somebody's asking does
it fly
he's got a 7 000 rug in the drawing room
he's got 1500 pound uh type of wallpaper
thing two sofas at 7 500 pounds each
that's a good deal 36 meters of fabric
for the sofa at 80 pounds per meter
pounds when you say
wait wait i think
more total and i'll convert it to make
it easier
okay okay let's see we see 208 104
[Music]
pull up your phone dudes you can do that
right here
it's a quarter million basically in flat
reservations that he was using people's
money on but it's government money but
is it for their white house because if
it's for their wife that's where his
personal flat with him and his wife you
know what though i do feel bad about
this poor country united kingdom because
like uh
uh this poor and former empire extremely
poor it's very poor they lost a lot of
their assets like india stuck yeah but
you know what happened is that their
president prime minister how much they
get paid is
like 100k wait that's like the same
thing with the u.s right no it's like no
400 no 400. it's 435
yeah and he deserves every penny
oh my god dude that's all they get which
means that he's definitely using like 3x
that amount for like flat renovations
he's definitely getting [ __ ] bribed
out the [ __ ] dude
my president didn't get bribed oh okay
never right whichever person is that
joe biden
people are mad that this guy spent 2 700
us dollars i said us dollars uh in gold
wallpaper for one of his rooms
that's kind of sick though it's kind of
fly that's really really fire dude what
if you what if your renovations are so
pimp though that like people saw the
cost and they're just like
dude what if he's the sickest politician
ever and he's like hey you guys want to
come in to take some instas
come on in no problem
i think the thing that makes it extra
dramatic is that there's a uh like a
cost of living crisis that's happening
in general uh across the world across
the world and obviously the uk is
obviously you know very much so feeling
that the prime minister is feeling it
man he's got a very low wage he didn't
get any stimulus checks so he needs to
[ __ ] get money elsewhere or else how
else is he gonna make the place nice
when he gets like different guests over
he's gonna pimp it out and then airbnb
it that's what it is oh you guys got it
all wrong passive income income i mean
he needs a cycle
dude he should do auto i'm telling you
i've been watching a lot of videos you
should do auto detailing yeah dude it's
car washing power washing is coming up
yeah and they drive up to you the prime
minister's like i'll come to you
they're mad that he spent forty four
hundred dollars on a uh forty four
hundred on dash that's crazy bro yeah
but if you look underneath it sucks your
dick
it's like the one we got back there but
it's like way nice like ours is like a
piece of [ __ ] right now this one's
really you should have put more money
into that one like that one's like total
piece of [ __ ] from the bathroom like
what is that yeah that one they made out
of like old bathroom pipes but this one
this one
industrial looks all right guys
don't you get started on this [ __ ]
room
[Laughter]
i'm sorry we couldn't get presidential
level [ __ ] product that's that's it i
vote for gold wallpaper you know i won't
go wallpaper dude give us a quarter
million like this guy we'll buy [ __ ]
500 people we just want
luna today
we can't give you what we lose all the
time yeah dude for real quarter million
luna in your pocket in a minute yeah you
know i got some luna too bro
dude this guy lost 37 dollars on luna
dude i got [ __ ] red
but it was hey you have to respect it
once that ride was great it was a great
ride best ride of my life you had 40 you
had 45 dollars at the high at the house
actually 47 dude watch your [ __ ]
mouth
that's your [ __ ] mouth man this uh
this wallpaper is kind of tight it
matches the sofas it was 2
looks like [ __ ] that's lit that's lit i
question all of his judgments now that's
that's gonna be a studio at the billy
studio no he's kind of artsy man that's
the billy studio this room ryan may
design this yeah it looks like you're
designing a haunted house
dude you don't remember all the weird
patterns and [ __ ] in the kubrick movies
yeah dude the weird patterns the stanley
hotel is not only like one of those
things where only a psycho would see
those patterns like if you don't see him
you're like a regular person no dude you
if you do set deco or anything like that
you ever been in hollywood your whole
[ __ ] life you ever written a movie
before you ever sold [ __ ] five movies
before no
definitely not and yeah we're here in
the same spot hey let me let me hey
remember when you're when i was making
movies you know what you're doing
[Laughter]
making movies and making moves
i always told logan paul what to say i
was doing that he's right there's me i
put the words in his mouth think that
son of a [ __ ] would have been
successful without me
i made him
oh what a troubled steve that is my
favorite logan paul movie though thank
you very much thank you which one that
obviously yeah
what's up so what movies did you like
what movies did you write again i
totally missed that one the thinning and
the sequel the meaning the world order
the new world order thank you
i don't get these white references i had
to think about it
you're totally missing it all right
it's like he's talking about his movies
[Laughter]
i don't [ __ ] get this [ __ ] dude i
don't get it either because my mdb has i
have like seven there's like seven steve
greens they're all me by the way
never consolidated all of them but it's
other people no no it's me but it's like
me a bunch of different times slightly
differently each time i wish that'd be
great
so many different ones i'm like all my
credit's all [ __ ]
the one without the e the one with the e
with the nightmare this is crazy you
can't get it together that sucks yeah
i'm sorry man and then they tie you up
with the [ __ ] vlog brother the the
green brothers dude it's destroying my
green
they thought you're the third brother
they used to do that to me i don't get
these white people references that's a
youtube reference you guys want a real
story that maybe we'll cut
true story um when i was whenever i was
at vidcon
i was always wearing my glasses and [ __ ]
and so people would
think that i was a green brother because
they remember my name is green but they
don't really know me maybe but they'd
like see me in other people's videos and
[ __ ] right
so this one this like young like i don't
know
15 year old kid comes up to me or like
13 or something he's like he's like hey
you are you hank green and i was like
yeah dude hank green
you just took it yeah yeah i was like
yeah sure i was like absolutely
uh we had lanyards and [ __ ] but i didn't
have mine at the moment at the time we
used to walk around with those in our
pockets and [ __ ] but i i swag
yeah we're way too cool to wear the
lanterns no but so he's like he's like
wow so nice to meet you and stuff i was
like yeah no problem he's like you want
to he's like can i take a picture i was
like absolutely of course and then i was
like hey real quick by the way just on
the low down not a big fan of jews
not a fan
and then and then take that into the
world
and green is not a big fan of juice
go spread it around the world i love how
this guy is like a 10 year old and
you've got to remember this from [ __ ]
he's like i bet he greeted i don't know
why he was like jews
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you